a business reached out to eight news now
asking for help to find a stolen parrot
earlier this week on Wednesday the
parent was stolen the Beloved bird was
has been part of the fish botch family
for 42 years what is wrong with people
the theft caught on camera at American
printing on Fremont Street near Maryland
Parkway that's where Madison Cambro
joins us live Madison
yeah I'm inside American printing this
business has been operating for over 50
years and next to me is an empty cage
where parrot Sam used to sit
he's been down here for 15 years and
nobody's ever bothered him or anything
so we have no idea why somebody would
take him but we need him here oh Brenda
fischbach and her family are missing
their beloved double yellow head Amazon
parrot Sam video footage shows the theft
taking place this man is seen on camera
breaking into the business wandering
around eventually making his way to
Sam's cage we have three garage Overhead
Doors one of them has a lock on the
outside and they broke that and got in
through the back
they set off the alarm Brenda's
brother-in-law Ron Johnson has watched
the security footage countless times
this guy who got who came in he he has
to have a lot of bites and stuff on his
arms and hands Sam was did not go
peacefully
as he should have he fought so it's a
good thing he had to search but he
bypassed a lot of expensive things to
get to the bird Brenda and Ron say with
the amount of people that come in and
see Sam on a regular basis they believe
they were targeted as birds of Sam's
kind can be worth a lot of money and it
had to be someone who knew that Sam
spent his Nights At The Print Shop we
want him to be safe he needs to be taken
care of we've had him so long he's 42
years old
Brenda and her family offering a reward
for anyone who can bring Sam home alive
as the bird needs to be medicated daily
for his joints now he's currently at the
final stages of his life we reached out
to Metro to hear how the case is going
it's still under investigation reporting
live in Downtown Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now